tout de suite c'est la revue de presse
avec vous hélène frade bonjour hélène et
on commence avec ses révélations de nos
confrères de mediapart sur robe jean
michel blanquer air d'après le site
d'info français le ministre de
l'éducation nationale se trouvait à
ibiza en vacances alors qu'il l'ait
annoncé un protocole sanitaire de la
rentrée pour le moins controversé à
l'école alors que les syndicats
d'enseignants appellent à une nouvelle
journée de grève ce jeudi après une
première journée de mobilisation massive
la semaine dernière ces révélations
tombent on ne peut plus mal pour jean
michel blanquer déjà régulièrement
vilipendé par les syndicats pour son
attitude jugée désinvolte
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
donc choix de rester au bel-air jusqu'au
2 janvier soit la veille de la rentrée
aurait provoqué des tensions au sein
même du gouvernement selon mediapart le
site rappelle l la colère provoquée par
la communication du ministre de
l'éducation qui avaient des avis dévoilé
elle est toute dernière minute 1 le
nouveau protocole sanitaire de la
rentrée une nouvelle organisation fort
complexe détaillé dans un entretien au
parisien qui avait choisi de pauline
d'ailleurs pour illustrer cette
interview une photo du ministre dans son
bureau dans son bureau au ministère à
paris en france toujours la justice a
condamné pour la troisième fois hier le
polémiste d'extrême droite est candidat
à la présidentielle d'eric zemmour pour
provocation à la haine raciale zemmour
le récidiviste fait la une du journal
local la marseillaise qui rapporte que
le candidat condamné pour sa déclaration
sur les mineurs étrangers qu'il a
assimilé je le cite à des violeurs et
des assassins a dit vouloir faire appel
de cette condamnation qu'ils jugent
idéologique et stupide eric zemmour qui
est de nouveau convoqué d'ailleurs ce
jeudi par la justice cette fois pour
contestation de crimes contre l'humanité
après ses propos sur le maréchal pétain
qui aurait selon lui sauvé des juifs
français à la une également l'élection
annoncée aujourd'hui on en parlait à
l'instant avec alix le bourdon dont la
maltaise roberta mais ceux-là à la tête
du parlement
européens d'après de malte à l'élu du
parti populaire européen devraient être
élus grâce au soutien des sociaux
démocrates on l'a évoqué un qui ont
accepté de laisser le champ libre à la
candidate des conservateurs l'élection
annoncée de roberta mais de cela n'a
toutefois pas été sans tensions selon
politico qui fait état des critiques
provoquées par son opposition au droit à
l'avortement toujours interdit à malte
qui est le seul dernier pays d'europe où
il reste illégal une position qu'elle a
défendues aux instances même de l'union
européenne à rebours d'ailleurs de la
grande majorité des eurodéputés la
presse internationale qui revient aussi
hélène on en parle et là encore dans le
journal sur l' attaque de drone sans
précédent qui a touché hier à abou dhabi
la capitale des émirats arabes unis une
attaque qui a fait au moins trois morts
et qui a été revendiquée par les
rebelles houthi du yémen vers les
émirats arabes unis ne sont pas en
sécurité titre al massira le journal
officiel de la rébellion houti dont
aucun membre assure que cette opération
n'est qu'un début et que son groupe a
lancé cette attaque parce que les
émirati qui font partie de la coalition
dirigée par l'arabie saoudite sont
revenus sur le devant de la scène
militaire au yémen
d'après courrier international cette
offensive inédite un des outils pourrait
également s'expliquer par le contexte
régional et en particulier par les
négociations en cours à vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien l'iran par
l'intermédiaire des forces ou tir qui le
soutient cherchant ainsi à mettre la
pression sur ses partenaires ses rivaux
pardonnez-moi réfugiés on ne se quittent
pas là dessus elle en avant de dire à
tout à l'heure pauline une nouvelle peu
réjouissante de la can la coupe
d'afrique des nations s'est même
historique pour la première fois des
femmes pour employer l'expression
consacrée vont arbitrer une compétition
du tournoi la rwandaise shalimar à
diamou kunzang arbitrera aujourd'hui le
match guinée zimbabwe avec l'appui de
deux assistantes pour l'arbitrage vidéo
une info du huffington post le site qui
rapporte également que des internautes
les canaillous se sont amusés à
détourner le scandale politique du parti
gate 1 les apéros à gogo organisée à
downing street la résidence du premier
ministre britannique boris johnson en
publiant sur une plate forme de conseils
aux voyageurs leurs commentaires sur les
qualités du lieu en tant que bar
discothèque l'un des rares endroits où
vous pouvez organiser une véritable fête
pendant les fermetures du coc vide pas
de restrictions mais beaucoup d'alcool a
notamment commenté l'un autre n'at il
pas avec l'ambiance est top merci
beaucoup et la n'sele la revue c'était
la revue de presse on se retrouve dans
un quart d'heure sur l'antenne de france
[Musique]